cette question à présent au chapitre
économique combien l'état at il vraiment
mis sur la table pour sortir la france
de la crise du kobe de 19 dans cette
dans sa dernière allocution emmanuel
macron parler de 500 milliards d'euros
et d'un plan européen à venir de 750
milliards
mais au-delà de ces annonces
spectaculaires quelles sont les dépenses
réellement engagées sont elles à la
hauteur de ces chiffres qui marquent les
esprits
on voit cela a tout de suite avec est
l'économiste jacques sapir en duplex
avec nous bonsoir jacques merci d'être
avec nous
bonsoir vous ne semblez pas croire le
président de la république quand il
annonce que 500 milliards ont été
engagés pour la relance pour quelle
raison ce scepticisme alors il ne s'agit
pas d'accuser ici emmanuel macron
d'avoir voulu propager des défaites news
mais il est très clair qu'il a au
minimum confondues les torchons et les
serviettes et c'est encore plus vrai si
on regarde ce qu'il dit non seulement
sur les actions du gouvernement français
mais aussi sur les actions de la
commission européenne donc je vous
propose de voir ça un petit peu on
détaille alors jacques comment sont
justement par les mesures de soutien que
voulez vous dire avec mélanger les
torchons et les serviettes l'écouter
c'est très simple stéphanie vous prenez
les mesures qui ont été annoncées les
mesures de soutien qui ont été annoncées
à différentes activités ou des grands
secteurs de l'économie
eh bien vous voyez que dans l'art le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
qui a été déposée le 10 juin dernier
il ya absolument nous aucune mention qui
est fait d'un chiffre de 500 milliards
les chiffres que l'on trouve et qui sont
pas négligeables par ailleurs un voisine
à peu de choses près à 43 milliards
alors oui ce n'est pas négligeable mais
ces 43 milliards c'est pas 500 milliards
et qui plus est c'est très inférieur aux
chiffres identiques proposée par
l'allemagne parce que l'allemagne elle
se propose de mettre 130 milliards sur
la table pour une économie qui a été en
fait moins touchés par l'accueil du
coronavirus que l'économie française
alors jacques
soutien justement l'économie ne se
limite pas ses mesures oui tout à fait
il faut savoir que dans le soutien il ya
d'abord le coût du chômage partiel qui
est très largement payés par l'état
il y a le soutien aux pme et il y as
enfin le soutien aux collectivités
locales
là encore on arrive à peu de choses près
à 43 milliards c'est quelque chose qui
est important sauf que il faut savoir
qu'une partie de cet argent a déjà été
dépensée par exemple pour le chômage
partiel et que donc ce n'est pas de
l'argent que l'on peut assimiler à un
plan de relance alors ça qu'à vous avez
aussi parlé du manque à gagner pour
l'état engendrée par la crise économique
à combien sont ils
oui effectivement c'est fanny il ya un
véritable problème de manque à gagner
alors on le voit ce manque à gagner il
va toucher différents impôts évidemment
beaucoup touché l'impôt sur les sociétés
et on aboutit là un manque à gagner 2 66
milliards auxquels il faut ajouter et ça
ne figure pas dans le tableau il faut
ajouter effectivement 4 milliards qui
correspondent à différentes exemption
d'impôt voire des pertes qui touchent
des recettes non fiscales de l'état
nous arrivons à 70 milliards alors oui
c'est important mais cet argent
ce n'est pas de l'argent frais pour les
entreprises donc c'est 70 milliards là
encore il ne faut pas les compter dans
des mesures de soutien pour l'activité
économique
alors jacques avons bien maintenant
sellem le coût pour le budget de la
crise du coville 19 et de ses
conséquences économiques
alors pour l'instant d'après toujours le
projet de loi de finances rectificative
le coût total c'est 157 milliards même
dire 160 milliards avec la dérive qu'il
y aura sur le financement du chômage
partiel
on est donc très loin des 500 milliards
et qui ont été annoncées ces 160
milliards ça correspond à 6 5% du pib
pour 2010 9 par rapport au pib estimée
de 2020 ça correspondrait à 7,2 pour
cent
rappelle qu emmanuel macron a parlé d'un
engagement de soutien de l'ordre de 20%
du pib
trenet de manière tout à fait évidente
on n'y est pas draka comment emmanuel
macron dont qu'arrive-t-il à cette
fameuse somme de 500 milliards d'euros
et bien parce qu'ils ajoutent aux
dépenses que va faire l'état ou au cou
qui sera supporté par le budget des
promesses de prêts qui sont faits aux
entreprises alors évidemment les prêts
ils doivent être remboursés c'est pour
ça qu'on ne peut pas les compter
de la même manière dans le solde
budgétaire et donc il faut rappeler que
sur ces prêts il a parlé grosso modo de
300 milliards auront effectivement 300
milliards plus 160 milliards on
s'approche des 500 milliards
sauf que là encore si on regarde
l'argent frais qui est apportée que ce
soit aux entreprises ou par exemple aux
collectivités locales ou encore aux très
petites entreprises
on est plutôt autour de 87 milliards et
87 milliards faut faire attention c'est
un sixième pratiquement des 500
milliards donc on le voit il y a une
très grosse différence alors dans 87
milliards et non 500 milles ou jacques
c'est quand même une différence
considérable vous signaler également un
problème du même ordre avec les
promesses cette fois de l'union
européenne oui tout à fait dans la
manière dont emmanuel macron à pro a je
dirais a présenté ses promesses il a
confondu plusieurs schwazer tout d'abord
il ya effectivement la proposition
franco-allemande qui portait sur 1500
milliards d'euros bien et c'est une
proposition
après il y a la proposition faite par la
commission européenne on est hélas un
peu plus sérieux 750 milliards d'euros
sauf que cette proposition n'est
toujours pas votée et on sait qu'il y à
un certain nombre de pays qui s'opposent
à ce type de montrent en particulier ce
qu'on appelle les quatre frugaux 1
l'autriche les pays-bas la suède le
danemark
alors où en est on il ya en termes de
subventions pure on en est pour
l'instant plutôt de l'ordre de 310
milliards auxquels évidemment la
commission se propose
inclure des subventions qui ont déjà été
d'une certaine manière mise au budget
pour 55 milliards voilà on va pas
chipoter on arrive
grosso modo à 365 milliards et le reste
ça devrait être là encore des prêts
faits aux entreprises ce qui est
important c'est que actuellement ce sur
quoi travaille la commission de
bruxelles
c'est plutôt de 560 à 1 615 milliards
suivant ce que l'on introduit là dedans
on n'est même pas au niveau de 750
milliards et donc on voit bien il y as
loin de la coupe aux lèvres
dans ce cas dit emmanuel macron à l'orge
action vous comprends bien pour vous un
emmanuel macron c'est un petit peu trop
avancé dans sa dernière allocution
oui mais si vous voulez stéphanie il
faut pas non plus être dupe il est
évident qu emmanuel macron fait de la
politique il est tout à fait évident
qu'il cherche à présenter de manière je
dirais intéressante pour ses futurs
électeurs
l'action du gouvernement quitte là
encore à ne pas correspondre tout à fait
avec la réalité
il est aussi je dirais de son intérêt et
politiques de montrer que la commission
européenne et que l'union européenne a
réagi avec beaucoup de comptes itunes et
beaucoup d'efficacité a écrit ce qui
n'est pas du tout le cas et on le voit
très bien au niveau des sommes qui sont
proposés mais d'un autre côté il est
peut-être aussi de l'intérêt des
français de connaître les véritables
chiffres les chiffres qui sont indiqués
en particulier dans les deux dans les
documents de la commission européenne ou
dans le projet de loi de finances
rectificative merci jacques voilà qui
al'avantage d'être clair et qui va vous
faire évidemment on réfléchir merci à
vous
[Musique]